[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
I can't believe back welcome back thanks
I'm happy to be here I like how you just
immediately grab money I know I'm
obsessed with that isn't it nice yeah
it's all about feeling like you're gonna
get it one day
manifest yeah have you guys ever thought
about yeah
pulling out all your money just so you
can feel it and dump it back in well 500
bucks is not that much sighs do you mean
like empty your like thing yeah like
whatever you have or sell your bitcoins
perhaps just being very open why don't
you be slow like like some people they
empty their bank account some people
sell their bitcoins I'm just trying to
include everyone here he's being
inclusive this is what happens right you
withdraw your cash from the bank account
and then you put it on the feet and
you're like driving and you're happy and
you're getting a car accident and your
car flies up in the air and then the
money flies outside and then like people
go all free money and then they take it
it's gone damn what's your point
on the story you say no need to take
your money and then drive with it yeah
where things can happen you could put it
in a bathtub and you're like well an
earthquake happens and then the bathtub
falls down and then the money just
disappears into the ground yeah this
negative manifestation yeah that's awful
it's like a worst possible thing that
could happen I like a dream let's say
you take out a lot of your money and all
up not all of it and and then the
currency just tanks or some [ __ ] and
then you're [ __ ] because that we do
whole Bitcoin my family they had a lot
of money like the old Mexican vessel
before it changed and so all of a sudden
overnight like that money was worth
nothing really they could trade it and
find it until wave
Oh Mexico so unstable so cutely what
have you been up to what have I been up
to a month ago oh the last time I talked
to you you were you had gotten rid of a
lot of your YouTube videos yeah and you
were like rebranding and like
reuploading yeah I started posting
videos again I made 3 I shot the Malibu
Games I don't know if I did that before
after but they started airing which is
exciting that one year Malibu Games's
went like Malibu and you go to Malibu
rum Kenickie did that my way oh yeah
last year ok so yeah we went to the
Dominican no oh thank God you didn't die
I know I saw that when I got back like
people were just dying and going missing
and stuff did you drink from the hotel
bar um yeah did you have me any barber
uh cuz that's the word is a coconut
juice or something from it no but no
alcohol - welcome that's good you saved
your life so yourself everyone's dying
from the mini bar
huh got American specific we know that's
messed up yeah it's fun
I survived hell yeah it was bad I
remember you said that you're gonna
change up your channel and the stuff
that you're gonna do so what did you
change it - um honestly I'm like
embracing my blackness oh you did it
before talked about no I did I mean I am
black but um pretending to be white
before no I just was surrounded by white
creators it's like when I start of the
people in LA and like at the summit's
and stuff we're white that's true so
just the time I came up wasn't very
diverse yeah about how I'm glad it's
better now
yeah and there's a lot of more
representation talked about if it's okay
for gay guys to be attracted to straight
guys I talked about when I first moved
here and a producer made me cry reality
dancing show how did the producer make
you cry because he was trying to get me
to talk bad about my partner and I
didn't want to but he like won at that
like story all the drama yeah
and I was just like I don't want to do
that and it was a whole but how did he
how did you cry because he would not
move on select we shot you know when you
go back and shoot like the director
camera things yeah he was trying to get
me to say best stuff about her and he
wanted did he work you like where does
he like she said [ __ ] stuff about you
know
okay speeding me lying gotcha they know
over and over and over until I started
writing it's like when I first moved
here how old we that's 21
Oh Dan that's what I like how these
low-level producers think they're like
really like doing something like you
don't want your career to get better and
they're just saying all this [ __ ]
it's like dude did that ever yeah it
Aaron but I didn't say anything
yeah negative well good for you
thanks I didn't know what Ryan on what
about what were your thoughts on the
other video type of thing you mentioned
with like gay guys hitting on straight
guys yeah there's actually inspired by
the whole James Charles and tattoo thing
yes cuz I felt bad for him what's
happening cuz I feel like I don't know I
feel like gay guys aren't really or
lesbians or any body aren't allowed to
like just freely express themselves and
the way that straight people are what's
the day ever young boy has a crush on I
don't know he seems like a waiter that's
like hot he's like oh my god she's so
hot like nobody questions that
but if a gay dude sees a waiter and it's
like oh he's hot because we don't know
if they're straight or gay oh like well
he's straight but it's like we don't who
knows we're just talking about how
attractive I think that that's fine yeah
let's do it's fine of me well I think
it's also because we're from LA
hmm what are your thoughts on the whole
thing of like you know he's straight
well that is just roasting right yeah he
knew that they were straight but yet he
still wanted to pursue them but he did
it and actually the waiter hit on him
but that's a whole different thing just
so you guys know this is what he's
writing
satisfying things do you do you have
ever had the feeling that like so did
you always know you're gay no I may be
where did you say I'm gay when this dude
came into my job when I was like 17 and
gave me his number and wanted me to come
to his hotel room so he had a gaydar
yeah I guess so yeah yeah he was like I
know you gay even though you're not a
meeting it right now he was like hitting
on me before that I'm like an elementary
school nothing like my father is did you
oh no I couldn't
okay well you just told me like the
beginning of a story and I'm like oh
that's the best part he wanted to it was
a mess though I see my parents was like
keep my phone when I got home at night
and they ended up hearing the voice nice
what was a voicemail I was like yo I'm
Willie you met me at Friday's like I'm
just saying if you were gonna come
through like I'm very like I didn't know
and there's not one your parents that
person depends first time getting like
the gay stuff
well no cuz okay my parents are lesbians
okay I said when I thought dudes were
cute I remember one time my mom asked me
like if I thought one of the dudes in
beat UK was cute I was just like yeah
like I didn't it wasn't like a thing yes
yeah but this was like the first guy
Mario no I like it's a bug mm did you
have crushes on dudes growing up um I
think so looking back but like I never
acted on it okay I think you guys didn't
know I didn't know who was gay or not
and I was in Missouri
I don't know I don't even know what I'm
asking oh yeah no things like that the
reason why I don't get why I guess
people would get upset if a gay guy hits
on a straight dude because a lot of the
people that I've met that are gay they
had to discover it it's not like they're
a kid or some some are actually but it's
not like they know from the start I like
dudes mm-hmm so there's there's always
like this curiosity exploration period
so I can see from a gay guy's
perspective it's like well he says he's
gay he's straight now but if I ask him
out if I talk to him and if I if we if
we actually have an interaction then we
can see if he really is down to explore
whatever
straight people to like I remember I
went through a phase where I'm like man
all my girls like you know everyone has
yeah I don't know what people get mad if
people are hitting on people yeah in
even in I was gonna ask like the the guy
didn't know you were straight or not but
he still went for you right but then he
helped you kind of come out and realize
so I think that's why if a gay guy hits
on a straight guy it's fine cuz who what
if that straight guy might be gay dude
the James Charles thing yeah as me off I
don't even know the specifics do that
well the tachi chick is [ __ ] insane
am I crazy
I think she's she's a Fame horn she's
taken advantage of the whole situation
that's right uncle Tia no because she
I'm sorry
he didn't plug your [ __ ] vitamins bro
like that's where it all came from she's
like just so out the internet knows the
truth is he didn't point mines already
did a brand new girl she's 30 right
thank you
I'm like huh and he did a brat with his
mother and I'm like why his mom wouldn't
[ __ ] hound him about a Brad's what
angered me I thought I saw the part of
him hitting on a straight guys first and
I thought there was gonna be like this
whole expose like oh my guy he did this
and then yes he's forced someone to do
this and I watched her video I'm
embarrassed I watched the whole things I
did to Leslie like he sang like 35
minutes I've heard of being like I built
him up he didn't promote my vitamins he
was at Coachella he promoted my
competitors vitamins and then she just
randomly goes on this tangent oh yeah by
the way one time we were having dinner
and he said I want to [ __ ] the waiter
and he just has crushes on straight guys
all the time and then she went back to
talking about the other stuff it was the
most bizarre thing that I've ever seen
in my life
there was nothing like oh so he hit on a
straight guy a couple times and hello
and he used to pressure them cuz he has
a real big social media thing so he'd be
like if you don't [ __ ] me in a predator
I'll use my social media and will bully
you to [ __ ] me like what is all well
by the way that was just implied
never actually did any of this [ __ ] so
she's acting like James Charles goals
around a roof being straight guys
exactly words that she said the tone is
that but the words are so [ __ ] like
who carry homophobic it's Pete right
totally it's PG as [ __ ]
so yeah that's like saying Oh straight
guys shouldn't check out lesbian girls
because they're lesbian and think that
they're attractive what's nothing might
be like just straight guys in general
like input or anyone you guys have bug I
walked past you think he's like cute
like it's just a thought
yeah because of an attractive person is
there you just notice David Beckham is
unavoidably a handsome man oh yeah you
cannot get around it yes you kind of
want to get around him will be that
tacky chick man I can't believe that she
got such a huge influx of all this
support and all the [ __ ] it's because
nobody wants the whole video a lot of
people didn't write and then that's all
the title they go I'm outraged
there were titles and clips that were
very like if you would just watch the
clip you would think like Oh yikes what
is he doing yeah but then when you watch
her video and then him showing his
receipts and stuff like that it's just
like okay this is just a young dude
figuring himself out who like
occasionally has a crush on the wrong
person but he's not like killing it
completely innocent yeah it's not
[ __ ] Bill Cosby yeah that's what she
made it sound like literally crazy yeah
I know today we're gonna have you for
the oh damn I didn't even know that was
a thing like it like like people are
conflicted if gay guys can hit on
straight guys or even like them or
whatever it's like straight guys have
every right to say no and walk away from
the situation like why would that hold
my concept of like well I can't openly
just compliment other people because now
there's this notion that it's like well
you're gonna get I always been that way
I think just cuz of where I grew up I'm
not used to vocalizing if I think a guy
is attractive because I didn't know
who's like punch me in the face yeah I
mean like the Midwest so I a lot of us
have grown up like that
yeah and we don't have that freedom that
again straight people have to just do
like in high school like oh yeah I think
this girl is cute I can skies cute so
it's not good face to that way but
that's the thing I think like saying it
to your friends is one thing just being
able to have open dialogue and then
hitting on someone or harassing them is
a totally different yeah gay people have
like two layers to this [ __ ] if you
can't just be you're in high school and
you're like I have a crush on so-and-so
it's like first I have to like come out
to people so that people are aware of
what I what I like and don't like which
is already kind of praying down right
it's crazy the one video where they
reverse the roles and like this was a
whole new different like reality where
instead of like gay people like everyone
being straight and gays are them and
minority everyone was gay and straight
people were the minority and there's
these little kids that are growing up
and there's this little girl who likes a
boy and they're like yeah you're
straight and like definitely remember
this yeah I saw that and I was like oh
sure I never thought of it like that or
I mean you do but not like when you're
in those shoes of someone that's getting
bullied and stuff for it their sexual
orientation that just really made me
open my eyes to that yeah yeah it's so
weird cuz when I grew up like everyone
would be like oh that's gay or whatever
like you say those words but I never
thought anti-gay people mm-hmm like I
was like I was thinking why can't they
get married like why can't they be
together like that's just normal but
then you still use those words in a
different meaning or a way they just
they're gay if they want don't want to
go watch a movie with you yeah it's like
it's like you want to go chill go to the
beach and they're like nods like why
being gay you do you do homework but I
didn't tie that word - homosexual
neither hey yeah yeah really cuz you're
more about context right yeah I'm very
much about context let's a lot of people
are not and I get it but like certain
words just don't bother me and like I
loved with Hilary Duff did that
commercial that was like dissing the
girls I said that's like I just found it
funny I don't know wait what was it what
you do
no they said that's so gay I'm like a
shoe store and then she was like um how
about we not do that what if somebody
said that so and she like shaded her
outfit oh yeah and then like walked away
like a boss ass [ __ ] I love her and so
your other video was about race right
mm-hmm and then that was specifically
about what it was about how the time
period I came up on YouTube like 2010 to
12 ish whatever was kind of the popular
creators were pretty much white mmm
reference like DeStorm and glozell and
we'd like all be at these things and it
would always just be like a few of us
yeah but now YouTube has launched like
YouTube black engines for YouTube
YouTube Latino the what's the women's
one it's like something anyway like the
initiatives for marginalized groups yeah
that have really like helped I think
showcase more diverse do you do know
what timothydelaghetto us
I love do you consider them black I love
Tim I feel like you left our crew and
you went to the black side you know it's
funny is oh gee YouTube though like Oh
708 it was only agents and whites and
dog videos or cat videos and so the
Asians played guitar and sang yeah Ryan
Higa
right number one like it was number
forever yeah but I think it's it's funny
that we're a very small group in the
States less than 5% of the population
but on YouTube we had a pretty big
presence so I'm in the world dude holy
[ __ ] oh if you think about why yeah we
make a big number but there was a
diversity like thing and and we went to
a couple panels and at VidCon and all
that this was like like 2010 or whatever
and it was just mainly it was like
pretty much 99% black people and Tim so
I'm sitting there and I'm like how is
this diversity it's just all black
entertainers so then now the Asians were
like left out so then it's like when you
try to pack it all in into
group it's not really fair cuz it's not
just one group like like oh it's like
not just one white group and then all
the other colors you know it's like now
there's just so many that's coming out
on YouTube yeah it's much better which
is awesome I think we got to stop just
hanging out with Asians though that's
our thing
well I mean is different now I mean I
don't know do you think you have it on
purpose for me it just its proximity so
like most of my friends have been Asian
and Mexican because just where I'm at
but yeah it's like you have access to
these people right but now with online I
think you have more of a way to connect
with like-minded miss so I'm seeing less
of people getting together because just
like race and safety it's more like
people are into anime or people are into
kpop and you see all these like it's a
multicultural group that's into kpop or
something like that yeah and I see it in
thought more than I do see race groups
I think what's cool about me is like
whether you're white or black or Asian
or anything like you feel like anime I
don't like you you're I'll get you into
anime man and you can try if you like
story you're gonna get into anime or do
you think Adam is gay no I'm trying I
don't know what considered like I used
to watch like you guys a anime
yeah that's anime yeah yeah I left oh
c'mon but that's I get it I think did
you stay with Pokemon after the first
know like at indigo league right no once
the guy what's that thing called I just
have it with all of them listed the
Pokedex after like a music I was done
thank you you're a good person
I grew up yes yeah so you grew up into
you you actually yeah see that's the
that's the that's how gonna be at three
and you go ahead like 3:30
Digimon and I was like this is too many
moms I've never got into saying hi did
oh yeah
I like watching kid shows because I
would smoke weed and feel like a kid
again Wow is that why pilots watch kid
show I think so when he was a kid right
when you were you were nine you were
like I'm like six again yeah
pretty it was like a time warp you know
you get high and you're like a child
again and you just eat chips and watch
shows kind of sad but it's warm it feels
good my old brother came out to me and
told me that he watches a man I haven't
talked to me too good man now there's
gonna be like i watch anime like coming
out videos just for Steven I would live
for that actually I want a trend where
people come out stupid things yes I'm
coming out I drink gas
[Laughter]
[Music]